my guest tonight is the emmy winning
star of the insanely popular series the
marvelous mrs maisel now you can see her
in
two projects good god streaming on
amazon prime
the new movie i'm your woman and the
very funny
yearly departed please welcome rachel
brosnahan rachel thanks for being here
thank you for having me i'm amazed that
you're here promoting two projects at a
time when it's impossible for people to
make
anything so i tipped my cap to you if i
had a cap
thank you i it i'm just so insanely
grateful to have something to talk about
besides politics the weather and
the the dumpster fire of the planet
right now yeah
i i'm and you know i'm thrilled i just
saw this picture today because you
posted it but that you are still
able to be you guys are making uh more
of uh
marvelous mrs maisel and you posted this
picture
that i want to show of you now it looks
like you're in an
oxygen tent um this is you uh
working i guess in some kind of a bubble
this allows you to stay
safe is that true yeah that is a
brilliant invention
by our coveted safety team it's a it's a
hepa filtered
umbrella and we are taking pitches for
the name
so please submit any and anything and
everything to us
yeah this is called a celebrity bubble
that's what it is
[Laughter]
i just think they should still have
award shows but everyone should have to
walk down the carpet
in one of these like wouldn't that be
kind of
interesting and fun yes
thanks for thanks for playing along with
that uh
no i'm really looking forward to a time
when where i feel like it's
i think we all feel this way like it's
close the vaccine is out there
we don't know when we're gonna get it
but at least we think
maybe sometime in the next couple of
months so
yes there's light at the end of the
tunnel i promise you
i mean i said i did i said dumpster fire
of a planet but that was that was
a little bit further in the past today
like you said i think
especially yesterday i feel i feel
hopeful
yeah there is definitely light yeah no
wait no it's nice it's
nice we're in sitting in the back seat
of a car and now it feels like at least
someone with a driver's license is
behind the wheel
so yes do you know that's a little bit
the feeling that i have
uh these days um i know like it's so
hard for all of us
to do anything fun during this
quarantine
my family and i we had this idea which
is we'd take a road trip and literally
just stay in our car as much as possible
and i know that you did something kind
of like that you and your husband got in
an rv
is that right yeah we had the same
thought
and and that was a way that we i mean i
we actually traveled you mentioned
yearly departed we were traveling from
new york to la to shoot yearly departed
and wanted to figure out how to do that
as safely as possible and to arrive
in in one piece but yes we have the same
thought
you took a a picture that you also
posted and i think this is your husband
in the rv
chilling out looks like uh it looks like
he's having his breakfast
and then for some reason there's a
cardboard cut out of
you uh behind him in the rv
what's what's all that about yeah so we
we wrap dearly departed um some of our
producing partners on the project a
company called done and dusted they
produced the emmys and if you remember
at the emmys the audience was filled
with cardboard cutouts so my wrap gift
was my cardboard cutout which was
swiftly defaced with all kinds of you
know
uh pee-pee and and other things that i
will um
leave for the imagination and uh and so
we
you know what what does one do with a
cardboard cutout
of yourself it's like i can't throw it
out that feels wrong
and so we we brought her with us and um
and she haunted us uh in the rv
in our dreams and now she's still here
in my apartment
yeah it's weird i mean first of all you
ask what does one do with a cardboard
cutout of
yourself i know the answer to that
question
um i've been having them made for years
and uh i just love i just love hugging
myself
um i've had a cardboard cut out of
myself and i've thoroughly enjoyed it
in every possible way because i'm a
narcissist but you guys look like you're
having fun with it because you've been
taking these pictures i don't know if
this is you or your husband
around the house but i i really love the
ones where like this is you i guess
leaning in with your dog yes or a dog
unless he's a cardboard cutout too
improper ppe
usage i have to point out yes that's
nice that's winston he's confused
you've got one here that uh of just you
it looks like uh just with uh bottles of
alcohol
just chilling yeah and then my favorite
though
i like any peeking photo this
to me that's the best use of a cardboard
cutout there's nothing
better than it in the background just
peeking out
to me i don't know to me that's the
finest use of any cardboard cut out it's
just peering out a little
bit i really screwed up not placing her
back here for this
for this interview yeah i think you know
we've reached the point in
in lockdown life where we've been
together for many many months
we we're getting our kicks from from
hiding the cardboard
cutout of me around the house and trying
to scare it
it works it's frightening you know what
you should do is just have it looking
out the window
because people burglars will always
think you're at home
so that's not a bad idea that's an
excellent idea it's also a great way to
let everyone know where i live
yeah i i did as i was saying it i
remembered
oh right uh she's really famous that's a
bad idea
trust me you've you've achieved a
certain level of fame where
where it's not a deterrent to have a
cardboard cut out of you
peering out of your new york apartment
great idea so
yeah i think we are like i mean what do
you i'm
i can't ask you because you you love
your cardboard cutouts i think
i think she's she's overstayed her
welcome but i i have
i'm struggling with the idea of like
cutting her into small pieces
and putting her in a garbage bag yeah
that that
sounds uh creepy and wrong yeah and i
would say
send her to me but that's again the
wrong message
my wife would uh
every idea i have is worse than the
previous idea
so let's just pretend i haven't said
anything
um you know one thing i don't know about
you but
i am finding out in this time that at
how terrible i
am at tech because in addition to making
the shows
i do podcasts and i have to and zoom
sessions with writers and i they're
always trying to talk me through
how to get on my computer and i've come
to realize
at this later stage in my life that i'm
awful
i'm the worst how are you at this
terrible
and i have no excuse i i was born in the
age of the
yeah well not born i lived a young life
in the age of the internet
i feel like more is expected from me yes
i have so many i have an excuse i have
an excuse
i was born in 1944
you
the computer you know i saw my first
computer we
it's i had the steam-powered kind that
you could crank in college
and so this is newer to me you have
no excuse you have no excuse for being
attacked
but it's changing so fast i feel like
i've gotten i'm
in this time i'm getting a crash course
and how every grandparent has felt for
the last 20 some odd years
but there's so many different platforms
there's so many ways to screw it up i
accidentally
got a new computer and was trying to you
know put all the old stuff on the new
thing and accidentally
disposed of a bunch of important files
just permanently deleted them
the the things that run the thing off
the computer i don't
know how to send i can't remember to say
this i don't know how to send
emails from a computer i only know wait
a minute
that's just wait a minute no that's yes
yes you can yes you can you can do it
but you but the way that it's displayed
and the chains and i can't figure out
how to respond to the right female in
the chain
i just it's it's bad it's really bad i'm
sorry you are worse than i thought
i can send an email and receive an email
um that's about it that's all i can do
but i'm but the fact that you're
struggling with that means
there's other i mean i have 13 000
unread emails
so i'm it's reaching a dire breaking
point over here
do you have um people in your family
like
are your parents like my my dad
actually is is really up there but he
can
he's pretty good at a computer my mother
never even tried
is your mom any good at this stuff i was
just about to say
so my dad right there with me my mom
undercover internet sleuth like
undercover could maybe work for the
government
level of internet sleuths she
has i i some kind of wicked google alert
out there on me
she sees everything and anything most of
the time before i've seen it or become
aware of it
my mother though has started doing this
thing where she fights she finds
everything but she knows that i don't
know how to find
most of it so she will um for example if
somebody is being quite rude about an
outfit that i wore on a red carpet you
know she takes that kind of personally
and i think she wants to help me so
she'll
she'll call me and she'll go uh she'll
go you know
rachel i thought you looked so beautiful
last night i loved your dress
i loved the color i just thought that
maybe if you had worn a different shoe
say a strappy sandal or or a
or a bracelet a different accessory it
would have really popped meanwhile i'm
getting simultaneously tweeted at by the
website going if she just worn a
different shoe a strappy sandal or a
bracelet and that's
like mother yes mother first of all i
love it you call her mother
mother please um i
i can go i can top that with because
my mother back in the day and she
wouldn't get this off the internet but
she would
read things in the paper that were not
nice about me
and then she would call me and she'd say
well i don't care and it was stuff that
i would not have seen
because i'm probably like you i don't
read stuff about myself
you know and she's not the mean stuff
exactly and my mother
who was well intentioned would call me
up and go well i don't care what they
say
i don't think you're shrill and unfunny
[Laughter]
mom i didn't know and she'd be like well
apparently the boston herald tribune
thinks so
but that's the last time i read their
paper and i'm like well okay now i know
too and i feel like [ __ ]
so everybody's happy everybody's content
i am glad for that reason
i i know it enough unfortunately to see
the
to see the mean tweets and the good
tweets and you know to have figured out
that they all cancel each other out but
it's gotta be so hard for parents
it's gonna be so hard for parents no
matter who you are
or what you do if you have if you're
public facing in any way
people are gonna be mean oh i know i
don't know how i mean
first uh you know if i have two kids who
are
17 and 15 and if someone wrote something
mean about them they're not in the
public
eye but if i even heard about saying
someone something something mean about
them
i'd go crazy uh my parents seemed
oddly okay with it
[Laughter]
no one could be meaner than paper
um so much to talk about first of all i
love this project
yearly departed uh i know that you had
to shoot this during the pandemic that's
why you had to
get in an rv drive across the country to
to shoot this in new york
um and you sort of you shot it in
different rooms but with very talented
people is that right
yeah absolutely it's a testament to all
these incredible women's talent that
they were able to do this
under the circumstances that they had to
yearly departed is a
is a comedic um sending off for the year
2020 we're saying goodbye and good
riddance to 2020
and we had a bunch of incredibly funny
women delivering these eulogies for the
year
for things for funny things that we've
lost this year and
they had to do it most of the time these
amazing stand-ups to cardboard cutouts
in the audience we're back on the
cardboard cutout tray
yeah but they were amazing they were so
funny
it was really a technical feat pulled
off by
so many women in front of and behind the
camera
and and men who support them and it was
it was um it was an incredible
experience we'd have somebody
you know we'd have tiffany haddish on
one stage delivering her eulogy for
casual sex
and on the other stage a number of a
number of uh of comedians
with ear buds in watching on a screen
reacting on a green screen and it was
all completely
you know composed together in
post-production yeah
had um one of my favorite moments is
tiffany actually
our head writer and one of our producers
best caleb
was feeding things off camera for
tiffany to respond to and i think she
said something like you know just
dance you know you're having a great
time dance tiffany
and she was like cool and you know just
went for it in full tiffany fashion
and she was like what am i dancing to
and it's uh
best going christina aguilera singing i
will remember you
and typically just crumbled into
laughter could not stop laughing not
really a high octane tune yeah
yeah every time she got a grip would
crumble into laughter again
everyone was in stitches it was at such
a weird time and for how strange it was
to shoot
the most fun yeah but i'll play that all
year
what i love about the project is you're
taking and i think that is the magic of
these times is you and all these very
talented women are taking this
very uh just the worst year any of us
can remember
and i always say that knocking wood like
i you know
let's hope that i think things are
getting better but you're
you're making something positive out of
it you know
and and it is so hard to
to do comedy i mean we have a bunch of
cardboard cutouts in our theater
and you know there's no energy to feed
off of
uh and so i was really impressed because
uh a bunch of these women are giving
performances where
they're getting that energy from
somewhere there's not
an insane audience right there feeding
it to them but they're
channeling it somehow which i i'm very
impressed by that
me too i mean i can't imagine how hard
it's been for you but but it's so
important we
needed to heal through laughter
from this year that affected so many
people for so many different reasons
and and it was such a treat
it really was and and i'm i'm so
grateful to all those women for giving
it their all we were
shocked by how some of those amazing
performances came together how you
really
i mean i don't think you can feel that
nobody was really in the same room at
the same time
yeah it's very cool i i also want to say
that i mean
clearly uh there's yearly departed but
you're also
uh talking about i'm your you're here to
talk about i'm your woman
this is um a movie that was i'm guessing
made
or shot primarily was it before uh the
pandemic
and so um and it's it's a gripping story
it's an intense story uh and
but um it's so it's such a different
project
from yearly departed but it's cool to be
out here right now talking about two
very different you know uh concepts
very different types of entertainment
yeah i mean that's the dream as as an
actor to be able to
work with such different and equally
talented groups of people to be
able to play such different roles i mean
i'm
i i'm absolutely still pinching myself
but i'm your woman for very different
reasons was an incredible experience to
be able to work with our director julia
hart
my fellow producer on the project jordan
horowitz orinze kenney
marcia stephanie blake who i've been
friends with for a number of years
it i i it's been an embarrassment of
bridges but
um but we had an incredible time on i'm
your woman shooting pre-pandemic
with these two amazing babies it's a
kind of
reclaiming of a 70s uh crime
drama and through a bit more of a modern
lens and
uh and swinging the camera on on the
women's
uh women's experience and on sort of the
characters who are
primarily on the fringes of those
traditional dramas
you know what's interesting is we're
about to show this clip which is you
sort of finding out that you have to go
on you know
back in my day we called it on the lamb
um
because as i said i'm from the 40s uh
but
you have to go on the run and um
and i was just one of the things that i
can anyone who's had
a toddler knows it's one thing to go on
the run
in fear for your life and this is in
this scene you're being told you pretty
much have to go into hiding
uh and that uh your husband's
disappeared he might be involved in some
very dark stuff you don't know what's
happened to him
but the idea of going and going through
that situation is bad enough
and you're doing this scene while
holding
a toddler and i just think going on the
run i will go on the run for my life
i will not take a toddler with me that's
where i would draw them
it wouldn't have been easy for gene it
wasn't easy to shoot but it was really
important
to our director julia to have a real
baby there yes
that experience feel as real as possible
for me
i love this scene because you're finding
out your life has been turned upside
down you got to go on the run you got to
go into hiding
and the whole time i'm just watching you
their character and you hold this baby
and i think oh my god
i've been through that i i i no i
couldn't go through that a lot of forks
during the shooting of that scene
any forks were thrown let's take a look
i know and upstaging you know never
perform with a dog or a baby
they say never do it uh here's a clip
let's show a clip right now from i'm
your woman
so i'm supposed to live you don't know
where for you don't know how long
and also you don't know if eddie's okay
just let me call him let him be the one
to explain it
you can't you're talking about my
husband no one knows where he is
you can't call him because no one knows
where he is
is anybody looking everyone's looking
and they're looking for you too
a nice house park
i like to take walks with a stroller i'm
very happy for you
i mean you're making a lot of people
very uh very happy
with i mean you've got these two
projects and then marvelous mrs maisel
so
you know godspeed you're doing the
lord's work
as i like to say thank you it has been
you know i feel like we need i have
consumed more entertainment during this
time
than maybe ever before so i'm i'm happy
to be able to provide
any kind of relief to someone who needs
it so thank you
i'm your woman and yearly departed are
out right now
on amazon prime video thank you very
much
thank you